♪ ♪ ♪
- Des milliers de tonnes de
rails s'entassent en périphérie
de Campeche, à l'ouest de la
péninsule du Yucanan. Les rails
viennent de Chine, d'autres,
du Japon, s'accumulent
de l'autre côté, vers Cancun.
Un peu plus loin, des traverses
en béton, devant la vieille gare
de Campeche, désaffectée
depuis la fin des années 90.
Elle sert de bureau aux
ingénieurs du Train Maya.
Rails et traverses seront
bientôt posés sur ce terre-plein
fraîchement bâti, sur le tracé
même de l'ancien chemin de fer
abandonné dont on voit encore
les rails au croisement,
làuuù, un jour, il y aura
un pont, sous lequel passera
le Train Maya, à 160 km/h.
Pour l'instant, ce début
d'infrastructure, c'est presque
tout ce qu'on peut voir,
car le reste en est encore
au stade de la vision, du rêve.
Ce rêve, c'est celuidudududu prs
Manuel Lopez Obrador, qui a juré
de laisser en héritage un nouvel
aéroport, une raffinerie
de pétrole, et le Train Maya.
Une grande oeuvre,
transcendantale, historique,
parce qu'elle va intégrer
à la république toute la région
maya du sud-est.
Pharaonique, c'est le terme
qui revient le plus souvent pour
souligner l'ampleur du projet.
Gigantesque : 1550 kilomètres
de voies ferrées tout autour l ,
dans cinq États.
Premier objectif évident : le
tourisme. À la fois les plages
et les sites archéologiques,
mais aussi le transport de
marchandises et de p e e e e en
dehors des zones touristiques.
Car la vision du président
mexicain, qui est originaire
de l'Edididididiste de Tabasco,
est d'abord sociale.
Justice sociale pour le sud-est
du Mexique, abandonné depuis
longtemps, alors qu'il procure
une richesse incalculable en
pétrole, tourisme, archéologie,
nature et biodiversité. Il doit
générer le bien-être des
communautés en les connectant.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le constructeur des 42 premiers
trains a été choisi et il
se trouve au Mexique : c'est
l'usine de Bombardier, dans
l'État d'Hidardrdrdrdrdrd'hui
propriété d'Alstom. Des trains
hybrides diésel-électrique,
dont plusieurs seront
des restaurants ou de longue
distance avec couchettes.
L'avis des habitants de ces
communautés mayas et métis
est en général pos
"Oui, c'est bien, c'est un
plus. Du transport, sécuritaire.
C'est génial, beaucoup
de gens vont venir."
L'avis des observateursattenti.
VICTOR HUGO LIZAMA,
guide touristique à Mérida
- Si l'intention, c'est de lier
le monde maya grâce à c
vous savez que c'est déjà fait.
Nous avons des autoroutes,
qui ne sont pas les meilleures
du monde, mais elles sont très
décentes, qu'on peut utiliser
et que nous utilisons maintenant
pour toute la visite du monde
maya. Comme ça, je s
si dois dire ce mot, mais
c'est un vrai gaspillage
de faire le Train Maya.
- Pour limiter au maximum
les exprûûûûûûûûteuses
en argent mais surtout en temps,
les gares seront pour la plupart
hors des villes, parfoisà des d.
"Le train maya est un bon
projet de développement, si
on respecte certaines données.
Ainsi, le corridor d
à Tulum pourrait être un succès,
mais pour le reste? Ça va
donner du travail, mais après?"
CLAUDIO OBREGON, historiens s ss
- C'est un grand projet,
le Train Maya, mais il est
arrivé 80 ans en retard.
Il y a qu'un seul trajet qui
peut être rentable, c'est
Cancun-Tulum. En dehors de ça,
ça va être, comme on dit ici
au Mexique, un éléphant blanc.
- 240 kilomètres, dont
la plupart des voies surélevées
en viaducs, devaient être
bâtis par les militaires.
Mais ces forages pour préparer
le terrain ont trouvé trop
de cavernes pour risquer d'y
planter des nnnnnnnnn
passera donc à ras du sol, sur
le tracé de la ligne électrique
à haute tension, loin de la zone
hôtelière dont les propriétaires
au tracé initial.
Difficile de les voir,
ce d d d d d d d d d décembre,
moins de 400 kilomètres
de terre-plein étaient couchés.
Il en reste à faire plus
de 1000. Aucune des 21 stations,
dont le design est
particulièrement attirant, n'a
été commencée, et on ne sait oùe
elles seront construites.
FONATUR reconnaît un retard
dû à la bureaucratie,isisisisise
de l'inauguration.
"On travaillera jour et nuit,
dit-elle, jusqu'à la fin."
Un pari impossible d'un
président do
se termine précisément en
décembre 2023 et qui a fait de
l'accélération des travaux une
question de sécurité nationale,à
passés de 8 à 12 milliards
de dollars canadiens